geht es gerecht zu in deutschland knapp
20 prozent der menschen in unserem land
gelten als arm
die reichsten zehn prozent der haushalte
besitzen dagegen mehr als die hälfte des
gesamten nettovermögens soweit die
zahlen gestritten wird darüber welche
lehren man daraus ziehen sollte wer mehr
leistet soll mehr verdienen sagen die 1
der staat soll am besten jede mein
einkommen geben sagen die anderen
reiche reicher arme ärmer ist das
gerecht unser thema heute in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde guten abend herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ja reden wir über
das was wir als gerechtigkeitsempfinden
vor allen dingen wenn wir auf einkommen
und vermögen schauen ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen
sabine werth ist bei uns sie ist
sozialpädagogin und mitbegründerin
begründerin und ehrenamtliche
vorsitzende der berliner tafel die tafel
verteilt lebensmittel spenden an
bedürftige und frau wert macht das seit
über 25 jahren ist auf grüner begrüße
ich vorstandsvorsitzender der cg gruppe
das ist eine der größten immobilien
firma firmen unseres landes und er sorgt
als bauunternehmer für jede menge neue
wohnungen
er schätzte sein privatvermögen auf 80
millionen euro
christoph butterwegge ist armutsforscher
bis 2016 professor an der universität zu
köln die linke hatten ihn bei der
bundespräsidentenwahl 2017 als kandidat
nominiert und herzlich willkommen
bettina weg boni kolumnistin und
wirtschafts reporterin bei der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
autoren des buches der eliten report
hellgrüner sie haben eben schon mit dem
kopf geschüttelt weil sich ihr
privatvermögen genannt hatte fällt sind
es nicht
das ist erstens ist unerheblich und
zweifarbig die zahlen die genannt hat
sie irgendwie den weg in die medien
gefunden und es gehört eben zu dem teil
der medien der nicht so spaß macht das
nämlich einfach mit überzeichneten
zahlen fakten versucht wird auf
irgendetwas aufmerksam zu machen es ist
wichtig darauf aufmerksam dass machen
aber jetzt hat der falsche weg mit
solchen überzeichneten zahlen oder mit
solchen dingen aufmerksam zu machen
schöne wärst du wissen wieviel menschen
beschäftige ich oder was für ein
unternehmen führe ich in welcher weise
für mich ist wenn man sich eben
wir haben es in der einführung gehört
mit der armut beschäftigen würde was
dahinter steckt und was wirklich das
bedeutet aber auch eben wenn man sich
die gleiche zeit nehmen für menschen die
erfolgreich bahnt sich mit den zahlen zu
beschäftigen die wirklich wichtig sind
ok dann fangen wir mal mit der armut wo
erleben sie armut
ich erlebe armut egal wo ich mich in
deutschland aufhalte ich lebe ich erlebe
armut vor allen dingen in der
vergangenheit als kind habe ich die
wahrgenommen schlimme armut nehme ich
die nicht relative armut die wir kennen
sondern eben die ernst nehmen der
einzelne armut wo essen wohnen raum oder
ähnliches nicht vorliegen ich erlebe
armut in vielen anderen ländern wenn ich
eben zum beispiel in san francisco durch
die straßen gehe und an jeder kreuzung
zwei drei leute liegen
man muss eben den begriff armut auch
wirklich genau betrachten und sich
darüber unterhalten
das bedeutet für unser land und wie ist
die armut definiert wenn die armut wie
bei uns definiert ist mit einem
statistischen wert dann haben wir das
gleiche wie wenn wir die reichen reicher
und die armen denn dann können wir
nämlich nicht wirklich damit umgang
pflegen
ich finde zb es wird viel zu wenig hier
in berlin über obdachlose gesprochen es
wird viel zu wenig darüber gesprochen
dass menschen wirklich nichts zu essen
zu trinken nichts haben wo sie wohnen
können und dann wird so getan als wären
20 prozent der menschen in deutschland
in dieser armut es stimmt eben nicht und
dadurch verliert man das auge für die
wirklichen schlimmen umstände die wir
teilweise sind auch in diesem land haben
also wenn die zahlen sagen nichts aus
aber das was jetzt als armut empfinden
aber leider erst mal da bin ich würde
weil ihr übergeben frau wird wo erleben
sie reichtum in diesem land nicht an der
tafel nicht an der tafel ich finde es
ist immer sehr problematisch immer nur
diese diese dimension reichtum und armut
zu beschreiben weil reichtum kann auch
absolut bei armen menschen vorhanden
sein das ist immer eine frage der
interpretation der dimensionen denn wir
denken
ich habe schon mit vielen armen menschen
gesprochen die gesagt haben wissen sie
mein leben ist total reich reich an
erfahrung reich an begegnungen auch
reicht dadurch dass ich bei der tafel
menschen kennengelernt habe die einfach
nett sind und ich habe wieder kontakt
zur außenwelt und von daher ist reichtum
für meine begriffe in keiner weise immer
nur eine monetäre dimension sondern eine
ein wirklich eine empfunden dimension
und natürlich kann ich mich als extrem
arm fühlen aber das kann ich auch als
reicher mensch und ich finde diese
menschen sind noch viel mehr zu
bemitleiden als die menschen die
wirklich betroffen sind reich an
erfahrung reicht nicht unbedingt um ein
gutes leben führen zu können natürlich
nicht also so einfach ist dann ja auch
nicht aber dennoch also ich habe
wirklich gerade vor kurzem erst wieder
ein beitrag gesehen da sagte die frau
ist einfach es ist ungerecht dass ich 40
jahre gearbeitet habe und jetzt auf
grundsicherung bin
das ist nicht schön aber die tatsache
dass ich von der tafel mehr lebensmittel
hole ist ein gutes gefühl und warum soll
ich immer zu jammern dann geht es mir
doch noch schlechter
das fand ich unheimlich wichtig weil wir
haben in der tat bei dem begriff
reichtum ein problem reichtum ich kenne
viele menschen die vermögen haben und
ganz armen zwerge sind und da kenne ich
in der regel sind die öfters dort
vertreten als wenn ich mit menschen die
ein erfülltes leben führen sprechen und
vielleicht nicht die finanzielle
ausstattung haben ich denke es geht ja
nicht darum zwischen arm und reich
sondern kann ich ein erfülltes leben
führen würde ich würde gern meine mutter
wege dazu gehören der mutter regel wer
ist für sie sehr reich und also wie
gerecht ist unser land dann ich würde
erstmal schon wert darauf legen dass
natürlich arm und reich was zu tun haben
mit einer wachsenden sozialen
ungleichheit und wenn man jetzt armut
und reichtum auf andere lebensbereiche
anwendet ich kann ja auch erlebnisabend
seien beispielsweise oder besonders
reich an erfahrung dann verharmlost man
natürlich das was sich da abspielt in
unserem land also dass nämlich die
reichen reicher werden und die armen
werden zahlreicher und das halte ich für
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und
für die entwicklung unseres landes für
ganz katastrophal aber ich will mich
jetzt nicht drücken zu sagen was ich für
arme und für raich halte also für
reichhaltig wenn jemand ohne sorgen und
ohne erwerbstätig sein zu müssen sein
ganzes leben gestalten kann und weiß
dass ihm mehr oder weniger in
materieller hinsicht nichts passieren
kann
wie hoch das dann genau ist ob das jetzt
zehn millionen sind oder wenn die zinsen
dann niedriges niveau haben ob es dann
vielleicht mehr sein muss das will ich
nicht diskutieren wobei man dann auch
klar sagen muss dieser extreme reichtum
den es bei uns gibt also herr grüne hat
gerade gesagt die 80 millionen sind
irgendwie nicht zutreffend aber was
wirklich
reichtum ist zum beispiel dass die
beiden reichten geschwister unseres
landes susanne klatten und stefan quandt
im mai dieses jahres eine milliarde und
126 millionen euro nur an dividende aus
ihren bmw aktien bezogen haben und die
haben sie geehrt die würden wie reich
auch immer herr grüner ist ihn
wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen ansehen
erst recht nicht an winterkorn oder
herrn ackermann mit 12 oder 15 millionen
euro jahreseinkommen weil das sind für
sie angestellte natürlich auch die
entwicklung des landes zu beeinflussen
wer politisch sehr reiches ist auch
politisch einfluss da kommen wir gleich
drauf ok aber was würden sie sagen ist
unser land gerecht in bezug auf
einkommen und vermögen also ich würde
sagen natürlich ist deutschland nicht
perfekt aber wenn ich jetzt mit anderen
ländern vergleichen
die auf der ganzen welt zu sehen sind
oder wenn ich das vergleiche mit
früheren zeiten wo ich es mir hätte
aussuchen können zu leben da möchte ich
hier und jetzt in deutschland leben weil
ich denke es ist relativ gerecht die
leute sind relativ gut abgefangen und
was besonders wichtig ist ist dass es in
deutschland immer noch die möglichkeit
gibt aufzusteigen also es ist es wird so
oft gesagt es sei alles start die
quandts sind reich und die werden immer
reich bleiben und das klingt so als
seien sie auch schon immer reich gewesen
natürlich sind die beiden reich weil sie
reich geboren wurden sind erben
aber der vater hat was geleistet
sonst werden die kinder jetzt nie reich
und ob deren kinder wiederum von dem
reichtum immer mal was haben es
überhaupt nicht ausgemacht also ist ein
auf und ab die durchlässigkeit der
gesellschaft ist immer noch da wenn man
sich die vorstände anguckt der dax
konzerne sind es auch steigert kinder
die hoch gekommen sind und genauso kann
es auch schnell wieder runter gehen
würde sie waren auch nicht immer reich
ist das ein punkt war sie habe sich am
anfang auch gewertet die armut auch
erlebt haben als kind ist das ein punkt
was sie
auf eine andere art sozusagen als also
ein leistungsträger auszeichnet ich
möchte es mal so sagen ich komme aus
einer familie die arme ist aber beamte
mit drei söhnen war schon ganz nahe
da und natürlich war dann der zugang zu
familien die arme waren oder zu
schicksalen da ich glaube eine ganz
wichtige sache ist es gerade aufgeworfen
worden
darüber zu sprechen dass armut ein
schlimmes übel dieser gesellschaft das
sind dass die steigende zahl der armen
unsere gesellschaft nicht zusammenhält
sondern ganz furchtbare explosive kraft
beinhaltet ist es einen haben der
anderen seite hin zu gehen und mit
pamphleten zu werben die in die
vergangenheit gehören und die wir schon
als irreführend und als nicht tragfähig
gesehen haben die ddr das ist eben die
umverteilungen propagieren ist das
andere
ich habe dafür zu sagen wir wissen heute
kein system das ist besser macht und wir
müssen überlegen wie wir in diesem land
für mehr gerechtigkeit bei der
verteilung sorgen
wir können aber damit nicht mit
althergebrachten um
verteilungsmechanismen wir brauchen
effizienz wir machen ideenreichtum
ich habe uns konkret zu machen müsste
ihrer meinung nach weil wir eben über
die familie klatten und quandt
versponnen müssen die mehr abgeben von
ihren familien wäre das sehe ich sehe
bei dem umverteilung von vermögen große
probleme die in einer globalisierten
welt auf deutschland zukommen und ich
würde dafür nicht werden wollen ich
werde dafür werben wollen dass man sich
überlegt wenn man eben zb mit dem großen
vermögen
aufwächst oder einst geschaffen hat was
macht man bei dem generationen übergang
ich glaube ich komme aus der aus der
sicht des kindes ich glaube dass jedes
kind eine leihgabe gottes reese
universums ist und dass jedes kind zum
beispiel welche chancen haben sollte und
man sollte sich überlegen wie schaffe
ich eine chancengerechtigkeit bei den
kindern und da ist glaube ich ganz
naheliegend das werden wir über
erbschaften und ähnliches sprechen dass
wir da dafür sorgen müssen dass der sohn
des herrn brüner nicht irgendwie besser
gestellt ist als der sohn familie meiner
die jetzt ein ganz schlechtes einkommen
hat und das werden sie durch eine
vermögensverteilung nie gerecht
hinbekommen weil wovon sie anfangen
die zum beispiel verhindert das was wir
jetzt haben
das wäre einen ganzen konzern den erben
kann ohne einen einzigen cent
betrieblicher erbschaftssteuer zahlen zu
müssen
das halte ich für total sozial ungerecht
und wenn sie sich wehren gegen
umverteilung kann ich das verstehen aus
ihrem eigenen interesse heraus aber der
staat verteilt ja auch um nebel man die
dividendenzahlung darauf werden 25
prozent steuern erhoben
wenn ich arbeite und viele überstunden
machen sagen wir mal als facharbeiter
oder als ingenieur dann kann es mir
passieren dass sich 42 prozent
einkommensteuer
ja aber das dann haben sie schlechte
steuerberater und das ist ihr problem
sie könnten sich aber welche leistungen
her sorgen würden dass das nicht der
fall wäre und da genau ist das problem
und ich meine ich würde jetzt auch gerne
noch mal was zu armut sagen sie haben ja
recht es gibt unterschiedliche formen
von armut
sie haben nicht unterschieden das ich
tun würde zwischen absoluter und
relativer armut also absolut arm ist
jemand der seine grundbedürfnisse nicht
befriedigen kann der nicht genug zu
essen hat er nicht ein sicheres
trinkwasser ich bin keine abstellen kann
das sowieso auf der ganzen erde könnte
man es abstellen wenn nämlich diejenigen
die
so ich nenne sie übrigens nicht
superreich sondern hyper reich weil wenn
mein kleiner dreijähriger sohn nachts
noch lebendiger ist als tag silber wird
er auch als hyperaktiv bezeichnen
verstehen sie also wer solche reichtümer
anhäuft bei uns sind es 45 reiche
familien die besitzen soviel wie die
ärmere hälfte der bevölkerung und da
kann es ja ein auf und ab von ausgeben
nur es ist ein paternoster effekt wenn
die einen nach oben fahren während
derselben zeit fahren andere nach unten
denn der reichtum basiert ja auf der
armut andere also niedrige löhne sind
gleichbedeutend mit hohen gewinnen das
ist ja noch die frage frau wert was
würden sie sagen sie was wäre gericht
gerechter also müssen wie könnte man
vermögen ihrer meinung nach sollte man
das anders verteilen als ich würde
grundsätzlich auch dafür sein dass die
steuer höher sein müsste um einfach an
dieser stelle was auszugleichen
einkommensteuer die absatz spd sowohl
als auch also ich finde auch das ist bei
der absatz steuer ist das eine sehr
heikle angelegenheit bei der
einkommensteuer meine güte warum denn
nicht wenn jemand extrem viel verdient
dann kann auch extrem viel steuer
gezahlt werden fall dass ich ganz
gefährlich tun um 49 prozent ist er ein
grundsteuer spiel sich dafür ganz wenige
sogar und mit reichensteuer über 50 ist
erst mal alle her
ja und jetzt finde ich auch nicht weiter
schlimm in der spitze da haben wir doch
nicht auf das ganze einkommen
doch jetzt nicht über mensch lernt
möchte den bürgerlichen einkommen
darüber zu sprechen von reichtum frau
werth ich glaube auch dass zum beispiel
die anhebung von von mehrwertsteuer eine
sehr heikle angelegenheit ist weil
natürlich wird da noch ein recht
untersagt die jene die die viel
konsumieren die zahlen dann auch mehr
als die anderen
ja aber es behindert viele die wenig
geld haben überhaupt zu konsumieren und
genau das ist das problem und deshalb
dürfte es nicht so eine eine steuer
seien die sowieso alle betrifft sondern
es müsste sich auf einer erhöhung der
stelle an der vermögenssteuer sagen sind
wir morgen was würden sie sagen wie
sollte man vermögen anders verteilen
oder sollte man es anders verteilen
sondern bei vermögen ich mich ein
bisschen schwer aber also
vermögenssteuer hatten wir schon mal da
gibt es probleme mit ist es nicht so
ganz einfach sonst wäre es nicht
zurückgewiesen worden
enthält das sind sie nicht mehr zusammen
und weil sie ein vermögen es kommt ja
wie gesagt also auf dividenden werden
steuern gezahlt das heißt wenn familie
klatten dividendenauszahlung bekommt
bekommt der staat davon auch was und auf
die art und weise es gehen es wird so
viele milliarden die umverteilt werden
ich glaube nicht dass das problem damit
gelöst wird dass wir einfach anfangen
noch mehr umzuverteilen gerade bei den
einkommen also vermögen sehe ich noch
ein bisschen variabel auch erbschaft 2
oder so aber bei den einkommen aus den
oberen zehn prozent oder so kommt fast
die ganze umverteilung nur wenn man die
eigenen also was wird damit geholfen
wenn wir diesen diesen berg an
umverteilung einfach strikt wieder
erhöhen und einfach so weitermachen aber
wir haben doch jetzt schon nächstens
meinung kunden nehmen das
verfassungsgericht hat irgendwann gesagt
und aus guten gründen
wer arbeitet sollte nicht mehr als 50
prozent davon ab gemessen das ist
richtig und 70 und wir haben jetzt hier
im moment radien eine diskussion die
wieder genau in die alte geschichte geht
sie werden mit umverteilung szenarien
nicht die zukunft dieses landes
begeistern können bestreiten können wir
haben ganz andere probleme von den
träumen wir heute noch alle
wir haben ein europa das muss sich
demnächst integration gefallen lassen
100 millionen weil wir haben
zukunftsaufgaben wo es ganz andere dinge
geht die totale armut von der sie
sprechen das ist eine anstrengung einer
klar denkend regierung egal aus welchem
lager sie kommt das ist beenden und zwar
kurzfristig wenn wir uns ein ber eine
philharmonie und ähnliche dinge und
afghanistan kriege leisten können dann
kann ich nur dazu auffordern innerhalb
von wenigen minuten dafür sorge zu
tragen dass keiner mehr in dieser
schlimme armut ist das ist gesunder
menschenverstand aber nicht die heilung
da möchte ich noch wasser ein
umverteilungs das falsche was ich nicht
verstehen kann ist dass jemand der
arbeitet gewissen steuer das hat es
bezahlt aber jemand der zu hause sitzt
und miete kassiert einen anderen
steuerzahler bezahlt was ich auch nicht
verstehen kann ist dass wenn ich also
irgendwelche kapitalerträge haben dass
die plötzlich aber wieso wollen sie
eigentlich nur die absolute armut
bekämpfen also die relative armut führt
doch zum auseinanderfallen der
gesellschaft als die angriffe mehr haben
als die anderen
das ist sozusagen ein kranker patient da
liegt den werden sie nicht dadurch dass
sie umverteilt werden diese leute nicht
zurück und das werden sie es schaffen
indem sie bildung in dem so
chancengerechtigkeit erleben sie die
kinder komplett machen indem sie den
leuten das werkzeug in die hand geben um
aus dieser armut herauszukommen
und da haben wir ein problem in
deutschland sind ganz anderes ist dass
die gesellschaft nicht mehr durchlässig
ist und es schaffen sie die leute mit
geld zu schmeißen es wird nämlich
derjenige der natürlich viel hat
argumentiert doch bloß nicht
umverteilung bildung wo werden sie mit
alle besser gebildet wären würden sie
womöglich am ende
ich gönne es den jugendlichen auch den
mit migrationshintergrund sehr würden
sie am ende womöglich auf einem höheren
geistigen niveau um die immer noch
fehlenden arbeits und lehrstellen
konkurrieren und dann hätten wir am ende
nicht die armut besiegt wurde hofen
arbeitsplätze hat die fahrer rufen
also ich bin der meinung bilden kann
viel nutzen also ich persönlich ein
beispiel dafür sohn einer
alleinerziehenden mutter nicht ehrlich
geboren ist aufs gymnasium geschickt
studiert danach aber arbeitslos viele
bücher gelesen viele bücher geschrieben
und dann professor geworden
ja aber ich ziehe daraus nicht den
schluss ich war so ein toller hecht
sondern ich ziehe daraus den schluss ich
hatte viel glück und heute ist es viel
schwerer l war einer derjenigen die im
niedriglohnsektor sind und an der armut
haben ein
hochschule frau bärengarten mut frau
wird sie machen seit 25 jahren diese
tafel beobachten hat eben seit 25 jahren
die entwicklung würden sie aus ihrer
beobachtung sagen da hat sich jetzt was
geändert dass es schwieriger geworden
sehen sie eine andere klientel wie ist
es wenn sie da sehen sie kinder merken
sie aufstieg also vielleicht können sie
das mal beschreiben dass ich wenn man
den praxistest ja ein bisschen haben da
hat sich natürlich ganz viel geändert
zum einen durch die akzeptanz tafel
gegenüber dadurch gehen durchaus mehr
leute hin aber wir dürfen eines nicht
vergessen bundesweit bei über 900 40
tafeln gehen 1,5 millionen menschen zu
den tafeln das ist immer noch ein
kleiner prozentsatz derer die arm oder
von armut bedroht sind sind also das
heißt es geht gehen nicht alle zur tafel
das ist schon bei der wesentlichen
punkten
das ist natürlich eine menge aber gut
der wesentliche punkt ist was wir
beobachten ist dass etwa ein drittel
alte menschen zu uns kommen und ein
drittel alleinerziehende mit kindern
der anteil der kinder und jugendlichen
ist einfach gewaltig groß geworden aber
auch der alt werdenden aber das ist auch
ein demografisches phänomen wir sind nun
mal eine etikette oder alt werden der
gesellschaft eingehen dass ich interesse
vertreten das ist absoluter unfug ich
weiß nicht wie viele menschen ich habe
zu schützen di so 10 15 20 ihrer
privaten einkommen karitativ einsätzen
nicht dafür ja weil es mir spaß macht
und weil das mir ganz viel energie gibt
und weil es mich über die trauer hinweg
hilft die ich täglich draußen sehe ich
bin ein mensch der traurig sein kann
sehr traurig über die umstände die ja
jeden tag hier im land erlebt ich bin
deswegen dagegen weil sie aus ihren
politischen lage ganz oft nicht erkennen
dass wir in einer globalisierten welt
sind und dann schauen sie einfach mal
nach frankreich
die haben eine vermögenssteuer gemacht
eines kapital abgeflossen dann sind die
arbeitslosenzahlen nach oben gegangen
und das land stand vorm ruin
jetzt ist die vermögenssteuer wieder
abgesetzt und das empirisch belegt das
ist klar vermögenssteuer weg das kapital
des zurückgekommen arbeitslosigkeit ist
zurückgegangen
und wir haben plötzlich weit bessere
umstände auch in den einkommen
strukturen innerhalb von wenigen jahren
erreicht
dadurch also auf die chancen für kinder
von alleinerziehenden tal ist die
voraussetzung für jede arbeitsstelle für
jeden erfolg in das kapital aus einem
land abfließt ist es vorbei wenn sie
etwas mitnehmen dann ist der kapitalist
nicht dramatisch in gefahr solange die
leute das geld verdienen wird einsetzen
und das ist nunmal natürlich fantasie
aber trotzdem die grundlage dessen was
wir versuchen müssten mehr her zu
bekommen wenn die familie klatten die
1,1 milliarden einsetzt arbeitsplätze
damit schafft und wieder in den
kreislauf zurück gibt statt irgendwelche
großen schiffe zu kaufen funktionieren
in dem land also nicht vergessen
aber weil wir haben dieses buch
geschrieben über die eliten sie haben
die menschen beobachtet in diesem land
die den aufstieg geschafft haben sind es
die würden sagen sind das die klügsten
die besten oder sind es die die halt
eben letztendlich den besten background
haben und von zu hause das meiste
mitgekriegt haben also wer schafft in
diesem land den aufstieg also was jetzt
gesagt haben will ich sagen weder noch
also sind nicht unbedingt die klügsten
und die besten es sind auch nicht die
die es von vornherein in die wiege
gelegt bekommen haben ja ganz ganz
sicher nicht also was diese menschen
alle auszeichnet ist ein enormer
machtwille ein aufstiegswillen der sie
einfach hoch hinaus kommen lässt indem
sie ihre ellbogen ausfahren indem sie
was weiß ich also sie sehen das alles
als als kampf an
kann auch positiv sein
das muss nicht böse sein aber sie wollen
da oben und sie stehen das durch ganz
viele andere auf dem weg nach oben
schaffen ist nicht also das ist glaube
ich das was diejenigen auszeichnet die
wirklich oben ankommen da gehört dieser
machtwille dazu waren ja also es gehört
viel dazu eben auch die ellbogen
es gehört eine eine vernünftige bildung
dazu
das heißt aber nicht dass das die alle
aus akademikerfamilien stammen ganz und
gar nicht also wenn man sich mit den
leuten zusammen setzt und sie fragt wo
sie herkommen oft ist es ja gar nicht so
klar was ist eigentlich der hintergrund
bei den dax-vorständen reden auch nicht
unbedingt gerne drüber sagen auch nie
unbedingt gerne dass sie aus einfachen
verhältnissen kommen sagen dann sie sind
heute ihr vater war hotelier was dann
rauskommt ist das ist ein mini gasthof
mit ein paar betten im westfälischen
land ist gewesen ist oder eine bäckerei
die eingegangen ist eine metzgerei als
es sind gerade viele aus so handwerks
familien die also sagen dass es möglich
auf jeden fall unsere gewählte diesen
auch ein shooter häuser leitet siemens
und er stand als sein vater bei
fabrikarbeiter einfacher macht will das
hat man einfach eine idee eine vision
meine berufung
der unternehmer nicht mehr manager des
in deutschland schöpft seine kraft aus
dem mittelstand nicht von irgendwo
zusammen also wer ordentlich ellbogen
uhr steigt auf und wenn er aufgestiegen
ist und unternehmer oder kapitalist ist
und die folge in was sie eben gesagt
haben dann müssen wir den campern dann
müssen wir möglichst geringe gewinn
steuern erheben erst recht keine
vermögenssteuern und erbschaftssteuern
die so hoch sind dass er sich irgendwie
da entsprechen sie haben doch sie haben
doch gesagt
steuern sind in einer globalisierten
welt was ganz schreckliches weil es die
das kapital vertrag ist hören sie doch
auf eines hat doch eben auch zugehört
hat 5
also sie haben gesagt das müssen wir
verhindern indem wir nicht eben auf
diese art und weise zb vermögenssteuer
oder umverteilung auf andere art und
weise bezwingen so was ist die folge sie
haben gelobt wie ihr karitatives
engagement
wir überlassen also das land denjenigen
die als unternehmer oder von mir aus
auch spitzenmanager dass die unternehmen
führen und warten ab ob sie karitativ
sich engagieren ich bin der meinung es
ist keine lösung wenn wir aus einem land
der dichter und denker zu einem land der
stifter und schenker werden sondern wir
wollen demokratisch legitimierte gremien
haben die entscheiden wohin die gelder
fließen und nicht reiche unternehmer
entscheiden wem sie zum beispiel etwas
zukommen lassen in karitative also das
ganze
danke für die reichen entscheiden wohin
sich das land entwickelt nein wir sehen
die demokratische gesellschaft und sie
muss steuer l nora denjenigen die sich
das leichte also jetzt nicht mehr sagen
also völliger unfug hier zu behaupten
dass die reichen und das ist die
leistungsträger dieser gesellschaft
keine steuern bezahlen ich zahle sehr
viele steuern und ein achtung doch sie
habe gerade so getan als ich es verpönt
es ist doch so ich kämpfe mit dem
finanzamt und das was ich an steuern
bezahle zahle ich wirklich gerne weil
ich einen beitrag dazu leisten ist weil
ich davon überzeugt bin dass dieses land
nur so funktioniert und ich habe genau
wie sie gesagt es gibt steuern die sind
einfach ungerecht nicht ausreichend ich
bin für ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für kinder bis 18 jahren
selbstverständlich ich glaube wir müssen
einige hersteller in deutschland
wirklich ändern und wir müssen dafür
sorge tragen dass ungerechtigkeit dass
jemand zuhause sitzt nicht so viel
strand bezahlt wie jemand der am band
steht das kann nicht sein da müssen wir
wirklich dinge überlegen wir müssen auch
überlegen wie gehen wir mit vermögen die
quasi über die generation weitergereicht
werden auch um auch da müssen wir
überlegen wie machen wir da weiter aber
ich sage ihnen dass die besteuerung von
vermögen wieder auf diese alte auf der
alt gebackenen umverteilungs theorie
wenn sie nicht wenn sie mehr umverteilen
schaffen sie mehr ungerechtigkeit das
können sie plötzlich in die ddr ist die
spitze der ungerechtigkeit gewesen und
da ist alles um verteilt wurde und das
müssen sie lernen das funktioniert nicht
wir brauchen effiziente systeme wir
brauchen effiziente werkzeuge dieses
land nach vorne zu bringen die
durchlässigkeit in der gesellschaft
wieder möglich zu machen und dafür sorge
zu tragen dass es spaß macht im land zu
leben und nicht vier millionen hartz 4
empfängern von den mindestens die hälfte
dem land den rücken gekehrt haben nicht
jedes jahr 50.000 schulabgänger die
keinen abschluss mehr haben da müssen
wir kämpfen und dann werden sie sehen
dass wir in der lage sind diesen
patienten deutschland wieder auf die
beine zu helfen
doch geld ist genug da dass der rundfunk
so lang wie
wir haben beispiele genannt die ich ja
zum teil unterschiedlich aus der bremer
trotzdem fehlt doch weil man zum
beispiel die soziale und
bildungsinteressierte ausbauen will dann
braucht der staat doch viel mehr geld
es fehlt doch an allen ecken oder halten
sich die finger gucken sie sich die
schulen besonders von denjenigen an die
in abgehängten stadtvierteln leben und
dann eher zu den angsthasen das heißt
hier rein
der müsse deswegen auch die reiche enke
hyper reichen zur kasse bitten
in einem vorschlag für mich ganz klar
geworden ich würde gerne mal einen
einfach dass wir ein stück weiter nach
vorne gucken nämlich wie wir das
hinkriegen und wen wir dann ins bett
überzeugen ja doch die
steuerverschwendung alle wegschauen sie
dafür dass auch bandenkriminalität und
sonst was nicht mehr existieren und
schwarz gearbeitet wird sorgen so dafür
dass blicken der betreuung unternehmer
das profitabel dafür dass das nicht mehr
passiert ist sicher nicht sehen sich
meine kritiker aber sie sind unternehmer
dh sie können doch dafür sorgen dass die
löhne steigen das wäre zu machen und die
gemacht doch er ich kann jetzt nicht
hinein gucken in die unternehmen die
zahlen ist heute ich sehe ja der
niedriglohnsektor wächst dass er
inzwischen ein viertel der bestellten
und fragmente welt der anteil ist im
bereich der sicher nicht so frei weil
ihnen was würden sie sagen welche was
welche aufgabe ist es diese in diesem
zusammenhang der politik zurück haben
über die unternehmen geräten welche
rolle die haben wohl sagen sie müssten
politisch stellschrauben gestellt werden
anders damit man sagen ein aufstieg ist
wieder möglich in richtung bildung zum
beispiel also ich denke zwar zwei punkte
sind auf jeden fall zu nennen das ist
bildung also so blöd das immer klingt
jeder politiker sagt wir müssen in
bildung investieren wir müssen in
bildung investieren
wenn man aber guckt und wir waren vorhin
kurz an diesem punkt wo eigentlich die
probleme sitzen es ist nicht eine ganze
abgehängte riesige bevölkerungsschicht
in deutschland unzufrieden oder den vor
sich her vegetiert es sind
ballungszentren und spezielle milieus
aus denen es schwer ist raus zu kommen
und da sitzen auch die schulen die das
problem haben und indi indi muss
tatsächlich investiert werden das muss
geändert werden
das kann auch nicht so schwer sein da wo
ich wohne die schulen in der umgebung
sind wunderbar die öffentlichen wir
haben kein problem dass die öffentlichen
schulen in deutschland schlecht sind
sondern wir haben regionen wo die
schulen ein problem haben da kann man
geld reinstecken und zwar gezielt in
diese schulen
warum denken sie passiert das nicht oder
wer versagt da sht respekt innerhalb von
vier jahren also sie sehen haben jetzt
als reines phänomen armut ist doch
inzwischen dabei die mitte der
gesellschaft hinein sich auszubreiten
gucken sie doch mal an das ist viele
menschen in liebe und sexualität auch
nicht weit auseinander das haben sie
vorhin schon gesagt dass nicht mitkommen
allein hier in deutschland seit jahren
nicht weiter auseinander
das ist die zahlen sind einfach so
würden sie sagen was würden sie sich
wünschen auch nach dieser ganzen
erfahrung die sie da haben dass sie
sagen wo könnte man relativ einfach wenn
man jetzt politiker wenn sie politikerin
wären was ändern
ich glaube wirklich dass das thema
bildung tatsächlich das wichtigste ist
weil wenn wir den den kindern eine
chance geben sich intellektuell auch so
zu entwickeln wie es ihren möglichkeiten
entspricht dann schaffen wir eine ganze
menge möglichkeiten das mir lange das
wissen wir unheimlich lange genauso wie
das hört sich alles so erstaunt sind
dass wir so viele alte haben hallo
das sind demokratische zeit
demografische zahlen die sind präsent
und das schon seit jahrzehnten wir
wussten doch wie sich alles entwickeln
und wenn wir wenn wir zwischendurch
diese sogenannte herd pauschale dafür
gezahlt haben dass die kinder nicht in
die kita gegeben wurden sondern zu hause
behalten wurden die aber gleichzeitig
wussten dass die förderung in den
familien an manchen stellen nicht mehr
optimal funktioniert dann ist das
verheerend und wir haben viele jahre
verloren durch diese maßnahmen müssen
doch jetzt also für meine begriffe ist
es so wir haben in berlin die situation
dass die die gelder für die
schulsanierung zum teil freigegeben
waren aber nicht abgeflossen sind nicht
abgefordert worden
dann heißt es jetzt aktuell nach jahren
wo das aufgearbeitet wurde es gibt keine
firmen mehr ja natürlich nicht aber vor
ein paar jahren hätten wir die chance
noch gehabt wir sind immer irgendwo
hinten dran mit allem was die politik
entscheidet ich glaube dass die die
lobbyisten viel zu stark sind dass immer
wirtschaftlicher ideale im vordergrund
stehen es geht immer nur wenn mein leben
glaube ich meine zum beispiel das eben
bestimmte entscheidungen in bezug auf
bildungs gleichheit so nicht getroffen
werden wie sie getroffen werden könnten
das in bestimmte stadtteile abgehängt
werden wenn wir das merken dann müssen
jedoch möglichkeiten schaffen und zwar
die politik möglichkeiten schaffen dass
da wieder etwas passiert und wenn unter
wenn unternehmen sowie das unternehmen
ein grüner sich der sicher für kinder
engagiert wenn die sich engagieren
finden sie das dann gut oder nicht dann
finde ich das toll als übergangs
möglichkeit wir müssen aber
standardmäßig der ausgleich für
politische defizite sondern wir
versuchen hilfe dazu geben wo sie
notwendig ist aber wir machen die
politik auch gleichzeitig immer darauf
aufmerksam dass wenn die besser
funktionieren würden keine tafel
existieren müsste und das fängt bei den
lebens erhält bei der
lebensmittelverschwendung an und endet
bei der armut der menschen also dafür
nur noch was zur bildung sagen also ich
bin ja nicht jemand der sich dagegen
wendet die schulen und die bildung in
unserem land zu verbessern also ganz im
gegenteil nur ich finde das zum teil so
heuchlerisch dass man sich hinstellt ich
weiß nicht ob sie dazu gehören aber
politiker sind zumindest da an der
stelle heuchlerisch die predigen den
armen bildet
bildet euch bildet euch das unterstellt
in klammern dass die armen selber schuld
sind weil sie sich nicht gebildet haben
so und dann was machen diese politiker
jetzt zu ende zu was machen diese
politiker die die bildung für so wichtig
halten die fördern privatschulen die
führen studiengebühren ein
die schaffen die lernmittelfreiheit in
der schule weitestgehend ab dass sich
die hartz 4 bezieher kaufen doch das
leisten können ihren kindern
entsprechende mittel zur verfügung zu
stellen weil das tun hier was sie
eigentlich tun ist wenn sie wirklich
ernsthaften dazu camp bildung als mittel
gegen soziale ungleichheit einzusetzen
müssen sie doch die barrieren senken
gerade für die kinder aus sozial
benachteiligten familien genau das
machen dass sie nicht glaubwürdig zu
bleiben ist heute kein politiker die am
tisch sitzen haben und ich darf ihn als
unternehmer folgende denkweise dazu
sagen wenn ich unternehmer bin dann muss
ich meinen betrieb dafür sorge tragen
dass der betrieb funktioniert nehmen wir
den betrieb deutschland jeder politiker
und jeder der hier verantwortung trägt
und nicht dafür sorge trägt dass
schulklassen nicht mehr 30 sondern 20
haben dass tatsächlich alle kinder die
gleichen möglichkeiten haben der bildung
zugang zu haben lehrmittelfreiheit zu
haben sonst was versündigt sich an der
zukunft dieses landes das problem ist
dass wir ein wahlrecht haben das alle
vier jahre neue leute auf die bühne
bringt und dass jeder der sich darin
investiert den erfolg morgen nicht haben
wird bei den erfolg von kindern die wir
heute ausbilden die dann eben die chance
haben die armut zu entgehen
der wird sich in 10 15 jahren einstellen
deswegen haben wir keine lobby für diese
menschen und deswegen kann ich nur
appellieren oder ich kann auch nur
kritisieren als unternehmer die neben
dem unternehmen zwar noch kein
unternehmen weil ich hoffe es wird auch
ein es wird jedes unternehmen gleich
neben dem unternehmens wirkliche
gesellschaft die möglichkeit zu
prosperieren indem sie das wichtigste
gut nämlich die kinder nach vorne
bringen letzten minuten dieser sendung
nutzen um jetzt in die zukunft zu
schauen wie wäre dieses land gerechter
freuen
das was wäre dann wie wie sähe das aus
müssten die reichen dann einfach viel
weniger haben müssen alle dasselbe haben
müsste es viel mehr gleichheit geben ist
dass gerechtigkeit also vielleicht noch
mal in dieser halle würde er gern mal
schauen das gleiche haben weil auch
nicht jeder einen job haben möchte wo er
verantwortung für 10.000 mitarbeiter
trägt wo er die politik bestimmen
das hat nicht jeder lust drauf ist kann
nicht jeder den sie nicht die
möglichkeiten aber die möglichkeiten
müssen gegeben sein und wenn sie sagen
ja bildung ist schön schulen sind sind
schöner aber dass das legt nahe dass die
kinder auch lernen müssen einen
schulabschluss haben müssen als ob sie
das von sich aus nicht haben wollten
darum geht es doch gar nicht das problem
ist wenn die schule ein ort ist wo man
wirklich weder die lehrer noch die
schüler gerne hingehen wollen dann
fallen viele raus und diese fielen
heraus fallen was vielleicht zehn
prozent eines jahrgang sind die sind das
problem weil wenn man keine schule
keinen schulabschluss haben einen
ausbildungsplatz hat dann das ist
wirklich würde ich sagen das größte und
fast einzige problem was flächendeckend
ist die kriegen keine jobs die kriegen
keine wenn sie doch einen niedriglohn
jobs bringen ist das denn dann weiter
gerecht müsste man lernen doch den
mündlich erhöhen muss man nicht dass in
das ein doch ein grundeinkommen ein
frauen also wenn man jetzt in so eine
vision mal gucken wie könnte es in hat
mir nicht nur einer wahlperiode sondern
wirklich auch ein bisschen weiter schaut
also was wäre denn dann eine gute also
die weiterbildung natürlich mindestlohn
ist eingeführt worden es wird darüber
debattiert ob er erhöht wird wenn die
mieten weiter so steigen was glaube ich
dass auch die wohnung
etwas wie könnte es gerechter sein in
diesem land in diesem land ist
gerechtigkeit dann möglich wenn kinder
zugang zu bildung haben
wenn kinder in problemvierteln nicht bei
32 kindern mit sex täter in deutsch oder
80 die kein deutsch sprechen ihre schule
unterricht fahren sondern wenn wir dafür
sorge tragen könnten das in einer
schulklasse zwischen 20 und 22 kinder
sind wenn diese schulen so ausgekleidet
werden dass auch die kinder dort zb den
nachmittag verbringen können ein
mittagessen bekommen selbstverständlich
und natürlich dort auch die möglichkeit
haben ihre hausaufgaben zu machen und
der betreuung natürlich auf freiwilliger
basis aber sie dadurch die möglichkeit
haben es nicht vielleicht dem zu
entziehen was sie zu hause erwartet wir
müssten eine steuerfrau machen die eine
klarheit in der steuerreform ich finde
zum beispiel alle steuer tatbestände die
jemanden ermöglichen keine steuern zu
bezahlen als irgendwelche abschreibungs
modell und so war es schrecklich das ist
falsch und nicht richtig jeder der geld
verdient soll genau die menge an steuern
bezahlen die vorgesehen ist und es
fördert auch meistens falsche dinge
ich möchte dass alte menschen in diesem
land in zukunft nicht wahr altersarmut
angst haben müssen und dafür brauchen
wir einen viel effizienteren und viel
besser funktionieren staat der auch
klarer ist und den menschen nicht etwas
verspricht was er nicht halten kann
und da haben wir eigentlich die großen
probleme das dauernd versprechungen
gemacht werden und dass wir das in
diesem land versucht wird mit
klassenkampf theorien gegend wie die
menschen auseinander zu bringen wir
brauchen eine gesellschaft in der der
leistungsträger und der weniger
leistungsstarke an einem tisch sitzen
und sich gemeinsam sie lassen sich
daraus ein erzieher übrigen heiß ich
übrigens das modernste werk der welt
sich mit dem kostenpflichtig wohnen alle
in sanaa ihre chance ja auch
chancengleichheit am tisch herr
butterwegge was ist für sie ihre mission
wo sie sagen würden das so will ich
gerne deutschland haben nur so wäre es
gerechter möchte die ursachen dieser
sich vertiefe die kluft zwischen arm und
reich beseitigen die erste ursache ist
die deregulierung des arbeitsmarktes für
raunen höheren mindestlohn
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass leiharbeit
entweder verboten oder stärker reguliert
wird wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
prekäre beschäftigungsverhältnisse
zurückgeführt werden überführt werden in
sozialversicherungspflichtige da muss
der sozialstaat entwickelt werden zu
einer solidarisch
die bürgerversicherung alle müssen
einbezogen werden auch freiberufler
selbständige beamte abgeordnete und
minister
alle müssen ein zahlen übrigens auch
kapitaleinkünfte müssen vorbei tragt
werden warum nur auf löhne und gehälter
von arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
beiträge erheben warum soll der
millionär nicht auch ein zahlen beiträge
das wäre eine wichtige martin und dann
eine solidarische soziale steuerpolitik
machen also nicht wie jetzt eine
steuerpolitik nachdem matthäus prinzip
im evangelium des matthäus heißt es wer
hat dem wird gegeben und wer wenig hat
dem wird auch das noch genommen
mehrwertsteuer erhöht noch mal richtig
nein also das ist eben nicht so sondern
die erhöhung der mehrwertsteuer hat dazu
geführt in einer ungerechten in diesen
ungerechten steuersystem die
alleinerziehende mutter im
hartz-iv-bezug wenn sie in den laden
geht und windeln kauft zahlt sie 19
prozent mehrwertsteuer der reiche der
sich ein reitpferd kaufte zahlte bis
2012 sieben prozent mehr wetzlar der
ganz reiche der sich ein aktienpaket für
30 millionen euro zahlt überhaupt keine
umsatzsteuer mehr weil die regierungen
kohlen und seit 91 die
börsenumsatzsteuer abgeschafft hat also
das ist doch ok richtig frau wert was
würden sie dann was ist ihre vision was
ist ihr wunsch wie könnte das in zehn
fünfzehn jahren weil sie arbeiten mit
den 19 an der tafel haben sie mir vorhin
gesagt es ist schwierig zu sagen was ich
mir für die zukunft wünschen würde eine
gerechte umverteilung ist auch wirklich
eine relative geschichte weil einfach
nur zusammen die reichen müssen abgeben
damit die armee haben ich glaube dass es
wirklich ein politisches und ein
inzwischen gesamtgesellschaftliches
problem ist die die armen ich will das
mal ganz bewusst so verallgemeinern
haben einfach das gefühl abgehängt zu
sein in dieser gesellschaft nicht mehr
teil dieser gesellschaft zu sein und da
müssen wir dran und da weiß ich nicht ob
es jetzt unbedingt das nonplusultra ist
dass alle gleich viel geld haben das
glaube ich nicht sondern die politik die
wir erleben und das seit geraumer zeit
ist derart frustrierend und
desillusionierend für die meisten
menschen dass das gilt für alles allein
das gilt für meine begriffe ziemlich
umfassend ich will das nicht auf alle
beziehen aber ziemlich umfassend
warum haben wir denn ein
ja den zulauf bei populistischen
parteien und populistischen äußerungen
allgemeiner art was erleben wir dann auf
dieser welt und da bin ich ganz bei
ihnen
wir müssen global denken wir müssen auch
an dieser stelle global denken und wir
im augenblick habe ich das gefühl das
läuft so ein bisschen nach dem
rattenfänger prinzip da läuft einer
vorneweg der flöte schöne populistische
töne und alle rennen hinterher das ist
keine lösung
ich habe kein patentrezept für die
lösung aber sie haben erst mal
wunschvorstellung ich habe natürlich die
wunschvorstellung ich bin zum beispiel
für ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
auch wenn so und so viele sagen das
lässt sich gar nicht rechnen
wir haben aber nichtsdestotrotz auch
hätten auch dann immer noch die
ungleichheit weil natürlich würden dann
so und so viele wieder nicht mehr
trotzdem nicht mehr nicht arbeiten und
andere würden es tun und die farbigen
blieben erhalten dass das wäre natürlich
eine überlegung an dieser stelle nicht
für und wider
ich bin ein kritiker ich bin eher ein
kritiker weil ich finde es nicht gerecht
wenn nach dem gießkannenprinzip über
allen derselbe betrag meistens werden
1000 euro genannt verteilt werden
sondern zum beispiel ein
schwerstbehinderter ein blinder braucht
sehr viel mehr und herr grüner braucht
es nicht deswegen finde ich sinnvoll
nachdem gerechtigkeit prinzip dass ich
sie mir vorstelle mit dem bedarf zu
gucken und auch verteidigung
wir brauchen die gleiche die reichen
unbedingt auch noch kindergeld
da find ich also an dieser stelle finde
ich den umfragen nicht in politischen
vertretern diese diskussion zu
überlassen sondern dass wir beginnen die
menschen die betroffen sind einen tisch
zu bringen unternehmer menschen die
betroffen sind von armut und die mal
miteinander sprechen lassen und sich
konzepte aus der dinge die nichts mit
umverteilung und klassenkampf etwas zu
tun haben auch wenn wären sie ganz
sicher eine lösung haben die einen
beteiligten spaß macht und die ziel
führen dass anstatt dass man das
irgendwelche politischen
lage zu fallen ist und wirklich richtig
wegen eines hasen präsident werden oder
das sagen haben die unternehmer über
heißt doch nicht den kanzler auch nicht
weil sie ohne abend werden sich bei der
cdu und wirst du ja auch nicht ganz
herzlichen dank für diese muntere
diskussion bin sehr gespannt wie sie es
zuhause fanden und welche gedanken sie
sich machen über die gerechtigkeit
bleiben sie uns treu bei der phoenix
runde schönen abend noch bestandsschutz
[Musik]